i don't know if you've been paying
attention to this there's a guy named
brett weinstein there's a guy named sam
harris they have good representations
i would say of uh
of
two sides of a perspective on vaccines
so
from sam harris's perspective
it's obvious that everybody should uh
get vaccinated and
it's irresponsible to not get vaccinated
i think he represents a lot of people's
belief in that and then uh
brett
is talks a lot about ivermectin
but also talks about a hesitancy
towards the vaccine for
for people who are healthy who are
people who are younger that kind of
thing
and saying we should consider long-term
effects of uh the vaccine
in making this calculation
what do you make about this conversation
some of it happens on twitter
some of it happens in the space of
podcasts
um do you pay attention to this kind of
thing
what's your role in this
what do you hope
is the way to resolve this conversation
do you think it's healthy
well a conversation is always healthy
but to make definitive statements is not
because it suggests you have information
that you don't have so
um you know we talked about long-term
effects i think you need to balance
those versus long-term effects of the
disease and you can make your decision i
don't think
you need to
tell everybody to get vaccinated i think
you need to present the case you say
here we made good vaccines here the
safety profile
here's the risk benefit balance and you
should decide you're a smart person you
should decide
now
companies are going to do differently
right companies may say you have to be
vaccinated to work here my employer
columbia
said we have to be vaccinated to work in
the fall and if you want to be a student
you have to be vaccinated so you decide
whether you want to go or not
but
the the idea that
you should make a decision based on
long-term
effects there is no evidence right so
how can you make a decision when we
don't have evidence whereas we do have
evidence that there are long-term
effects of getting covet so i don't
think that's a fair argument and it just
makes people scared to say that
yeah but on the other hand for someone
to say it's a no-brainer and
to denigrate people for not being
vaccinated that's not the approach
either because
they're going to dig in and say i'm not
doing this because you tell me too right
i think the middle ground is to say
take a bit of both and say
hear the potential issues and hear the
benefits and
this is what i would do and you have to
just decide on your own i'd leave it to
them i say you decide and if you don't
want to you know it's up to you you
don't have to get vaccinated
and you'll probably get infected at some
point and maybe you'll be okay
but here's the best available data and
it looks like the vaccines are pretty uh
a pretty damn smart solution they seem
to work i think you
tell people what you did
and present both sides calmly and i
think digging in you know as like in a
debate i don't think that's terribly
useful yeah so that's my view i i mean
people come to me all the time and ask
me
i'm worried what should i do and i said
what are you worried about let's talk
about it and go through it calmly
and if they want to still take
ivermectin i said it's fine it's your
choice
i have a problem with that i love that i
love that's the way you think
you